[Music]
more than four billion people fly on a
plane each year but how many of those
know the planes biggest secrets stay
tuned to hear all about the airplane
secret cabins and how you can easily get
a first class upgrade don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out ten airplane secrets flight
attendants don't tell passengers don't
drink the water you'd think this was
something they'd tell you right but
there's one thing you should know
never ever order just water when you're
up in the air purchase soda or anything
else that comes bottled instead warmer
flight attendants warned that people
should never drink airplane water and
after hearing about this you'll never
order water again flight attendants will
never drink coffee tea or water on the
planes
unless it's bottled or their own and
there's a good reason behind it the
thing is the water tank inside the plane
that actually stores the water is
fertile II ever cleaned and if it is the
flight attendants have no idea when or
how often so you could potentially end
up with water from a tank that hasn't
been cleaned for months the association
of flight attendants issued a regulation
around airplane water cleanliness but
they only give broad discretion on how
often the tanks need to be cleaned the
AFA themselves don't believe that the
regulation is sufficiently enforced it's
also been reported that one out of every
ten commercial planes had at least one
positive test for bacteria found as a
result of drinking water no h2o for us
thank you open the blinds it's not a
secret that you have to open the blanks
during takeoff and landing but do you
know why many people seem to think this
is just for preparation to settle in or
get ready as you land you don't really
want to sleep all the way to your
landing and miss leaving there's
actually another reason why that must be
done at all times one of them is the
fact that the takeoff and the landing
poses the biggest challenge for the
pilots it's the time when the pilots
have to do the most
maneuvering themselves but it's also the
time where a lot of accidents normally
happen so opening up the blinds allows
not only for the flight attendants to be
alert but also the passengers flight
attendants reported that the passengers
will most likely be the first ones to
notice of something's happening to the
plane's wings and alert the crew
allowing open lines means that the
assessment will happen
faster and the situation can be quickly
controlled Boeing statistical studies
report that 16% of incidents occur
during takeoff and 29% during landing
but as long as you keep the blinds open
and pay attention to what's happening
outside there's a greater chance
everything will be just fine don't use
the bathroom at least don't use it
before takeoff and no it's not because
snakes might come and give you
nightmares for years after the reason is
similar to the reason why you need to
open your blinds during takeoff and
landing
if you desperately need to go to the
toilet before the plane takes off
there's a good chance the flight
attendants won't let you until you're up
in the air the reason behind it is that
you're number one or even you're number
two could actually delay the entire
flight when you decide to use the
bathroom before takeoff the flight
attendants have to actually alert the
pilots and wait until you're out and if
you take extra long everyone's gonna
know what you're doing legally pilots
aren't allowed to take off if the
passengers are in the bathroom of course
this is because of the fact that the
passenger could easily get injured while
they're doing their business but we also
can't imagine it's comfortable for
anyone to be doing that during takeoff
or landing so if you ever have to do a
number one or two make sure you do it
before you board the plane or hold it
until the seatbelt signs switch off they
have secret apps yep you heard that
right there are apps out there that
aren't accessible to anyone else but the
flight crew and some of them even depend
on the airline the flight attendants
work for flight attendants can use apps
like flight life organizer to organize
their trips and have a perfect overview
of their days off and locations they're
flying to when you're constantly on the
move you just need something to keep you
sane in 2015 United also came on the
news because of its weird app for flight
attendants according to the reports the
flight attendants were issued United
phones which replaced safety manuals and
have all information about onboard food
and other sales but for some strange
reason people discovered that the phones
also hold all personal information about
the passengers with this phone the
United flight attendants could allegedly
access all information the passenger
provided when they reserved the flight
including the rest of the itinerary the
incident was discovered when a flight
attendant wished a passenger a happy
birthday without the passenger room
sealing that information to them no one
actually knows what kind of information
these phones hold but according to
United it's there to help rebook flights
faster there are secret codes
did you know flight attendants sometimes
use secret codes saying things like
last-minute paperwork means that there's
a delay code Adam stands for a missing
child and if you ever hear the word
deadhead don't be alarmed
it's just airplane speak for a crew
member repositioning as part of an
on-duty assignment did you know that the
flight attendants love to gossip just as
much as normal people gossip at work and
that gossip comes with plenty of secret
codes this completely depends on the
airline and the actual crew you fly with
as it's more of a work thing than it is
a legal training thing a former flight
attendant revealed the secret codes
their crew used for attractive customers
because of course you can't just tell
your crew member to check out the
attractive person you need to be subtle
about it so if that attractive person
sits in 7a the flight attendant will say
something about spending seven days in
America if they sit in 10g
it'll be ten days in Greece and
apparently if a flight attendant says
they'll be right back it means they
don't like you we'll definitely be
keeping an eye on any strange
conversations in the crew area
don't touch the headphones or blankets
or any other airplane item you might be
tempted to use because of the
convenience this is a well known fact we
talked about it before but just in case
you're thinking of covering your body
with the airplane blanket think again or
putting in the airplane headphones the
reason behind it is that these items
don't get cleaned yep even headphones
end up repackaged and resealed at least
according to flight attendants airplanes
have a busy route that often consists of
no breaks for the actual plane so while
you might think that someone out there
is taking the time to take out old
blankets and headphones and replacing
them with new ones it's probably never
going to happen it just takes too much
time and it would cause major delays so
keep that in mind next time you're
tempted to use airplane headphones and
always remember to bring your own
instead chances are they'll be much
better at noise cancelling and they
won't come from someone else's ear a
former flight attendant also said they
never saw the trays being cleaned ever
but they did see plenty of babies being
changed on those trays so take this
information however you want to airplane
food
so we talked about water tea and coffee
and why you should never ever order them
on a plane but how much do you know
about airplane food in general do you
know why airplane food usually tastes
pretty average even though it looks
delicious there's a scientific reason
behind it when you're traveling in the
sky the cabin drops humidity and with
less humidity in your throat your sense
of smell and taste decreases to up to
50% but what also decreases is the
perception of saltiness or sweetness
which is why airplane food might seem
like it tastes so met so ordinary food
might taste completely different once
it's up in the air and it might require
much more seasoning to become just as
delicious as the food on the ground
North America Australia and Europe also
have strict rules on plane leftovers
because of the strict agricultural laws
the leftover food is never allowed to
leave the airport
unless it's donated to local communities
India actually has a high demand for
smuggled airplane food and you can sell
a plane food item for only a fraction of
the market value and yes crew members
can get fired for trying to take the
plane's food intense jobs
flight attendants actually have a really
important job in fact their training is
probably some of the most intense
trainings you have ever seen
for example the airline company Delta
has an intense two-month training people
have said it's actually easier to get
into Harvard than it is to get invited
to the Delta training flight attendants
have ranked Delta as the best plane to
work but it also comes with plenty of
preparations 150,000 people apply to
become Delta flight attendants but only
1% make it to the Train stage the
training is 8 weeks long and it includes
things like vaccinations CPR learning
how to evacuate the plane within 90
seconds and more the flight attendants
are also trained into pulling people
from the water into a raft in order to
be best prepared for the worst
they also partake an actual flight
simulator and experience what it's like
to really lose control over the plane
they must act quickly and make sure
everyone gets out as fast as possible so
next time you see a flight attendant
remember everything they had to get
through to even get to their job because
it definitely wasn't as easy as it
sounds secret cabins while the airplane
might look small to you it actually
holds more secrets than you've ever
known
for example did you know that there are
secret cabins out there only flight
attendants have access to of course this
only applies to long-haul flights where
sleep is pretty much needed naturally
flight attendants have to catch some Z's
just as much as you do most Boeing 777
and 787 actually have a secret deck
designed for flight attendants to catch
up on sleep it's usually accessible by
stairs the small deck has no windows and
bunk bed style beds with curtains to
give them some privacy usually these are
located right behind the cockpit in
first-class to make sure they're
undisturbed by passengers the staircase
is located behind a door that usually
needs a code to be opened other cabins
are camouflaged with just a regular
hatch that looks like an overhead bin
except instead of the usual compartment
you can find seven or eight beds in
there how cool is that compared to
regular airplane seats those beds look
really comfortable it's something you'll
never get to experience unless of course
you pass that intense flight attendant
training first class upgrade and here it
is the moment you've been waiting for
the secret that will get you that first
class upgrade at least according to
frequent fliers and flight attendants
many frequent fliers say that dressing
the part and simply asking for an
upgrade often does the trick and if it
doesn't make sure you fly solo as there
are way more solo tickets available than
there are group tickets
you should also travel during peak times
as airlines sometimes upgrade passengers
on flights they oversell it also doesn't
hurt to join the frequent fliers Club as
those customers are always prioritized
when it comes to first-class upgrades
one frequent flyer even claims she uses
the secret code called revenue
management when calling the airline to
ask about an upgrade she asks them if
the revenue management released any
first-class seats yet you should also
show up early and ask the agent before
things are busy chances are they'll be
able to accommodate you more when
they're not under stress and get you
that first class upgrade but most
importantly always remember to be nice
and kind to the people that serve you
you never know it might just be your
lucky day and that's all for our video
if you could travel anywhere in the
world right now where would it be let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]